[Musique]
je m'appelle david delattre je suis
gérant de la société alice adn qui gère
le restaurant la batterie on est dans le
domaine de la restauration nous avons
huit salariés à guyancourt 78 notre
activité est basée sur le restaurant la
réception de groupe le traiteur la
restauration du midi la brasserie
[Musique]
la société existe depuis un an et demi
je suis arrivé ici il ya environ six ans
j'étais moi même serveur et chef de rang
pour d'autres restaurateurs qui exploite
et le restaurant et ensuite ils sont
partis et j'ai fait j'ai répondu à
l'appel d'offres et c'est moi qui ai
décroché la gestion du restaurant
[Musique]
l'année dernière on a fait six cent
cinquante mille euros hors taxes de
chiffre d'affaires par rapport à l'année
dernière on a perdu à peu près 50% de
chiffre d'affaires malheureusement
aujourd'hui on n'a pas beaucoup
d'activités autres que la restauration
le midi
parce qu'en fait dans le restaurant nous
sommes dans un pôle musical dans lequel
nous avons des concerts nous avons des
événements tout genre est là
actuellement les concerts sont à l'arrêt
les cocktails entreprises sont à l'arrêt
également
[Musique]
j'ai bénéficié d'une faune résilience à
hauteur de 20 mille euros les dix mille
premiers euros en fait vont partir dans
un plan de communication pour pouvoir
développer notre clientèle deuxième
partie de cette aide en fait va être
pour le développement de nouvelles
activités snacks qui vente à emporter
pareil pour répondre un petit peu à ce
qui à la demande suite coco vide où les
gens veulent beaucoup de la livraison la
vente à emporter ce genre de choses
qu'il ne faisait pas donc qui va être
développée avec c'est avec cette simple
[Musique]